hey guys I've been getting a ton of
questions about whether or not dogs can
get sick with kovat 19 can they pass it
on to their owners and while I'm not a
vet I'm gonna answer some of those
questions today as well as giving you
some really important truths about how
to keep you and your pet safe during the
time of quarantine to make this happen
I've collabed with someone really
special it's my girlfriend
definitely stay tuned to that in this
video because bear and I are gonna open
some of your packages that you sent to
the PIO box yeah it's like a pandemic
for me to visit the post office to pick
up my packages alright let's get started
with tip number one from what we know
now there is no evidence showing that
dogs can get sick with kovat 19 there
have been a few dogs that have tested
positive for Kovach but it's been
thought that the reason they're testing
positive is they have some of the virus
on their mouths on their nose likely
from the owners that they've licked who
work ovid positive that being said if
you have kovat 19 definitely do your
part by staying away from your pet just
in case number two dogs like humans need
a routine they like to be fed at the
same times walked at the same time so
played with at the same time the more
you could stick to this routine the
better behavior you're gonna get from
your pup number three social distancing
applies not only to you but to your pup
as well when I walk bear everybody wants
to play with it but now more than ever I
have to respectfully ask that people
stay 6 feet away god forbid they sneezed
or coughed on their hands gotten the
virus on their hands pet bear I pet him
and I transfer the virus to my body it's
a no-go try and do your best to keep
your pets away from other people number
4
say no to dog parks I love watching bear
play with other pups especially small
ones like little French bulldogs but
during a time like this the last thing
you want is one of the dogs who
potentially licked one of their owners
who has kovat then plays with your dog
and then brings the virus home to you
number five
wipe your pups paws now this one is more
on the really safe side if you have
someone elderly in your home or someone
who's immunocompromised and you really
want to take that extra step to be
careful go ahead and wipe those paws
down remember these respiratory droplets
that people release into the air
eventually make their way to the ground
and if your pups been walking around on
the street they can put
we bring that virus home number six keep
an eye out for stressed-out pups with
kids being home from school many people
out of work dogs are getting a lot more
play time and while initially that's a
good thing sometimes it can tire them
out they also do a great job at picking
up on our body language you may feel
stressed out but you think you're not
showing it trust me
your dog knows some ways dog show stress
is by yawning acting erratically or even
having accidents after being properly
potty trained in those scenarios give
your dog's a timeout put them in their
crate or save space for them to chill
out number seven call for reinforcements
if you're sick the last thing you should
be doing is leaving your home if you're
experiencing Cova 19 symptoms but
remember your pup needs daily walks so
ask a friend or loved one to take the
pup off your hands until you recover
number eight consider a Tele visit for
your pet many veterinary practices
across the nation have been offering
these tele visits so call ahead to your
vet just like you do with your family
doctor number nine don't overfeed your
pup you don't want your pup becoming
obese and then increasing risks of all
sorts of health problems it's very easy
when you're spending a lot of time at
home to really increase the amount of
treats you're giving don't do that
treats should make up only 10% or less
of a pets diet number 10 train your pump
know that a well-trained dog is a happy
dog and there's a few tips I have for
you on that first keep the training
session short
dogs perform better that way to use
positive not negative reinforcement and
finally if you need help don't be afraid
to contact a dog trainer because there
are virtual options available there are
you excited to open up some packages my
first one is from Manchester UK oh it
has it has like a hawk seal I've never
seen him this excited dear Mike I deeply
enjoy watching your YouTube channel my
free time it takes me back to my
childhood years where my family and I
moved to New York City when I was also 6
years old just like you we lived there
for an amazing five years Oh some green
tea from winter Chelsea it's a little
bit beat up but we need a little green
tea to keep us going this is from
Nebraska hi doc firstly I just want to
say thank you for your content lately in
keeping us informed regarding kovat now
I'm an orthodontic resident with a side
hustle my small shop is called the Kota
ray and I
enamel pins for health professionals I
love this one it's a prescription pad
that says no bad days oh there's a
popular does that the school bought it
bear this is you danger test if it's
dangerous bark this is really high skill
of them look at that this entire drawing
is by hand fall it's a picture of Roxie
bear doesn't care because he doesn't
want to miss Roxy too much but I love it
Thank You Natalie bear this one's for
you
it's a pet first aid kit there are you
excited no seriously this is really
thoughtful whoever said this thank you I
will probably keep this in my car when
bear and I go hiking you know it's very
easy for them to cut their paws when
they go hiking and to have this kind of
kit available and on hand is huge wow
look at the packaging on this this is
legit whatever it is it's good two hours
later
[Music]
this is next level
there's a picture of me on Instagram I'm
gonna pop it up right here this is that
picture painted on a leaf the talent
level to draw this on a leaf someone
designed an anatomically very accurate
human body with yarn that's next level
it's all sorts of books for kids hello
dr. Mike we love you I just want to
start with that lol I had imaginary
pages we know some of your patients are
children we would love it if you gift
these books to them they don't know this
bears gone we actually have an early
reading program in my medical office
where these books are gonna be given to
children who cannot afford to buy their
own books and some of these books are
beautiful in Spanish do they know that
half of my patients and one of my
office's speak primarily Spanish my pet
ones a bit thank you so much for all the
gifts for me and bear I want you to
check out a playlist that I put together
of me with all my pet videos click here
or if you want to have yourself a great
laugh check out my last onion headline
video that one's a really a laughing
busting video don't know what I'm saying
it's kind of late at night but stay
happy and healthy
[Music]